can you tell us more what is and what
what a way what are we expecting from it
well first of all thank you uh thanks to
you uh your colleagues for having
organized this and all the uh the
friends who are watching from across
europe this this chat that we will have
together
the state of the union is for now many
years a highlight in the calendar both
of the european parliament but also of
the whole institutions
except this year it comes with an
additional challenge
we've already had two years
of pandemic we now have on top of that
war
in our on our continent with the illegal
invasion of russia into
ukraine and the ongoing unnecessary and
violent and brutal
killings of ukrainian men women and
children
we also have
[Music]
increase
in electricity prices
huge
social and economic impacts on families
on young people across the european
union as they feel the pinch of
unprecedented prices for what we would
call basic and essential services uh in
their in their
in their households we also have
very very rocky economic times we have
challenges for our industry we have
challenges for each country which has
its reality so what we are looking
forward to is a very very long raging
debate in a very difficult time
between the parliament and the european
commission next week
whereby the parliament will be asking
on where the progress has been made on
individual legislative proposals but
most importantly also how we are going
to respond to the very big problems we
have at our time which is what the
citizens want from us
well you already listed all the big
issues basically the the use facing
today and what are we going to expect
from that so i suggest that we have this
20 minutes so we go straight to the
questions that we received in advance
from together.2 community
this is a community created by the
european parliament where people can get
connected and talk about european
democracy as well as our social media
channels so let's see on your screen you
will see
messages from social media and videos
that will be played we will have a look
at it and then we come back to you to
hear your answer
and the first questions are of course
related with russians war in ukraine
people are very concerned you see
from instagram stories we have manu
who's asking how do you see the future
of ukraine in europe
well this is a very good question
let's just say
when i was elected
in january i would never have thought
that
in our continent we are going to see war
again
but from that war has emerged a new
reality a reality of a country which has
sought refuge in europe which is
fighting for european values which is
fighting for a war for the rest of the
europeans
on this continent against an autocratic
neighbor of the european union it has
also led to
a decision that three more countries
will become candidate countries uh to
the european union who would have told
us at the beginning of this year that we
would be in the situation we have also
seen a very strong and determined
decision also unprecedented of two
countries finland and sweden to join
nato
these are all consequences of the
geopolitical situation we are finding
ourselves in but also the understanding
that europe stands for hope europe
stands for democracy and europe stands
for freedom and when one country on our
continent has that at its peril or it is
being threatened then the european union
can no longer expect other actors in the
world to come in and solve the problems
on our own continents we did that for
far too long we looked away for far too
long even when our baltic and eastern
neighborhood partners were telling us
that there was a very big problem on our
on our hands that for far too long we
were dependent
on russian gas which is also a
discussion we are happy we are having
now as we move away as we uncouple our
dependence on russia as we make sure
that we do not continue to pay for this
war and all this is encapsulated in how
we look at the future that is why when
we look at the question of what is the
future of ukraine and europe i would say
that they are intricately tied together
we have the same goals and the same
values and it is for those values that i
have the honor of leading a european
parliament that has fought from day one
of this war that we will seek to protect
until the end of it
uh we had a very similar question also
from instagram um knowing that the war
is that's been going on for a while now
uh was its support for ukraine wavering
well
i would say that it would only waver if
we allow it to waver
i would say that
it is let's say
understandable that going into a very
difficult winter where the discussion is
now focused on high inflation
high stratospheric prices
the big gap between uh the richer
classes and the poorer classes youth
unemployment huge parts of europe that
feel frustrated marginalized not
represented by their political leaders
this is a real and essential daily
challenge that we need to address which
is what we will be asking also not only
through legislation but also to quick
and immediate policy decisions to be
taken both in a financial but also
social and economic aspect as we go
ahead in the next weeks and months to
come
but that should not take us away from
our promises and our commitment for war
to no longer have its place in europe so
this morning actually uh me and the
political groups all met with the prime
minister of ukraine
and we continued to to state our firm
and unwavering commitment
and solidarity both in terms of pushing
to ensure that the sanctions also
unprecedented the packages of sanctions
that we have adopted will be fully
implemented that there are still gaps
and also to go further how much more
further can we go with the sanctions how
many more sectors need to be targeted in
order for us to fight against
another war a hybrid war of propaganda
of misinformation
of
false
news po
um posted us astrut
this is something that we see every day
across social media channels across all
sorts of communication channels these
are the next steps we need to take and
once we take them once we realize that
there are still millions of ukrainians
that are still internally displaced in
ukraine they can't go back to their
homes what are we going to do it's our
responsibility to help in the
reconstruction and rebuilding how are we
going to continue to protect and give
refuge to those millions of ukrainians
who have been given shelter in such a
wonderful and loving way by european
citizens who opened their homes and
their hearts to ukrainians so i would
not say it's wavering but on top of that
i would say it's my responsibility and
my colleague's responsibility to make
sure that it does not waver
well i'm sure our viewers will be happy
to hear that
we do have a video question as i
mentioned from together.you community on
another very very important issue which
is climate change so let's have a look
through the screen as well
hello on behalf of enu this is our
question to the president of the
european parliament
how is the ep going to guarantee that
the eu doesn't lose focus on its climate
goals considering the global energy
crisis
well i would say thank you uh to shine
for having asked to ask this question it
is a very good question because
we were already on a very ambitious
track in the european parliament in
order to address
a challenge that has been
put aside for far too many decades we
are the last generation of politicians
that can actually do something about it
i need to make sure that my children the
next generations are able to say
that our generation has done something
about it has not only introduced
legislation has not only placed
ambitious targets but has met them we
are still very very far away from
meeting them in some countries more than
others but that is where leadership is
needed this is the time more than ever
where leadership and european union
unity has to show has to be able to say
that is a target that we can achieve and
that we are going to do everything in
our power for every country with its own
significant realities to be able to
achieve them i would not say that the
situation is different now if anything i
would say that if we had ever a moment
and an opportunity to invest more in
renewables to to absorb the potential of
wind and solar energy i was in in
portugal last week i had fantastic
meetings with youth um in portugal and
they all told me we have so many results
why are they not used why are we still
relying on unreliable partners for our
energy at the same time we need to also
understand geopolitical realities some
countries are more dependent sometimes
hundred percent on russian gas than
others how are we going to help those
countries in order to make sure that
young people in those countries can
continue to pay for their essential
services continue to pay their bills
continue to make ends meet at the end of
the month so i would use as a parallel
track on the one hand strong
environmental ambition on the other hand
strong economic situation that we need
to also invest in order for our
countries to continue to be economically
stable because if we don't have economic
stability we will have political
instability and that is exactly what
putin wants
and what we'd like to avoid right
and
now we have another question about the
rule of law also very
important one and first it comes from
linkedin
bjorn is asking
how can the you keep that and advance
our democratic values it's what
distinguishes us in this world and it's
our sustainable advantages some new
member states seem to believe that quasi
democracy is good enough it isn't well
first of all thank you to bjorn
he really puts let's say hits the nail
on the head a sustainable advantage is a
good way to put it in fact thank you
byron i will use that term because
we can be proud of the values that we
share it is not they are not just values
that exist in thin air they are on paper
and for every country to join the
european union you have to prove that
they are practiced and in force and
possible to be strengthened and
protected in each member state but we
have also seen that once member states
or once countries join the european
union it is sometimes quite easy to
forget the promises you made when you
joined and sometimes we realize that we
don't have the tools in order to make
sure that what you did when you entered
the european union has to be kept up
which is also
a demand of the european parliament that
we have a conference a convention on the
future of europe not only on the future
but also to discuss where the gaps are
and we have realized that there are gaps
in making sure that our rule of law
toolbox is strong but let me also tell
bjorn something and everybody watching
us if it were not for the european
parliament we would not have that
toolbox if it were not for the european
parliament we would not have a
conditionality
rule in our financial structure because
for us that was important that when we
are asking
taxpayers to make sacrifices when we are
putting money at the disposal of eu
governments we want to make sure that
they spend it well do they all do no
they don't that's what the european
parliament is here for
we have another question the video
question from together.you volunteer
also about the rule of law so let's have
a look to the screen again
i asked the european parliament why do
they not sue the european commission so
the european commission would implement
infringement procedures upon the member
states which do not respect the rule of
law in the european union
thanks a lot nika
thank you for for that question
i would i am a president that likes to
cooperate with other
eu institutions i think we can be
able to discuss
and we cannot always do it in court
i think that's why the politics of
persuasion
and arguments good arguments have led
for the european commission to take
additional steps against individual
governments and that is why there are
quite a lot of infringements that are on
the table i also thank
my 704 colleagues members of the
european parliament that have come
together time and time again
when there was infringement of basic
media rules when there was infringement
of the judiciary when there was
infringement of the state aid rules in
order for the commission to take action
against one member state or another
sometimes that has meant that yes
proceedings before the courts were
necessary and that is where in fact the
european parliament acted i look forward
to the next i say two years a little bit
less than two years before we are in
front of the citizens in 2024 to prove
to them that this parliament the only
directly elected institution of the
european union has done what its
citizens have asked for whether we act
on migration we act on the rule of law
we act on the environment we act against
autocracy and i want to be able to say
that we used all the tools at our
disposal to do that i think we've done
that so far we can do more and i can
assure you and i can assure nika that we
will
thank you
well another important issue that eu is
facing is digitalization so we have
another video question
from jesus so let's have a look at the
screen
hello this is
spain and i'm here from entertainment to
ask you how do you plan to conduct uh
the political
work in the uk and parliament to better
enforce the human rights newcastle with
the european union thank you so much
rights in the digital sphere yes we
didn't used to talk about that a few
years ago when i joined the european
parliament having data legislation or
privacy legislation was really still far
away but then the european parliament
managed to push through
an unprecedented regulation called the
gdpr which is general data protection
regulation and last july we took a
historic vote on the digital services
act and the digital markets act with the
aim of making sure that consumers are
protected privacy is a foremost concern
but also the companies digital companies
technology companies on which we rely
but which we need to ensure continue to
be a force for good and not a force that
is abused of by autocracies by other
malign players in our world also
something that we are going to look
forward to the ai act the artificial
intelligence act you know ruta other
countries around the world look to the
european parliament and the european
union and look at our legislation in
order to try to push forward this
balance that we have found in this house
also in those countries i take that as a
big compliment but also one with big
responsibility because fundamental
rights what what was just asked in terms
of human rights when we are talking
about data how data is used but also how
it can also be a force for good and
research in technology in all areas uh i
was also i mentioned what you call i
visit for example medical institutions
how much they need to rely uh on on data
and privacy but also the technology and
the software needed and the investment
in in our researches in our universities
for us to have that competitive edge
over other
countries that have been raised with a
much different value set to uh to ours
that is what our legislation seeks to
strengthen we need to continue to do
more but now also the ball is in the
court of the governments that the votes
we take here are actually transformed
into rules that apply on the ground it's
not always easy and sometimes we take it
for granted but that's what the european
parliament is for
and uh well then it's time to talk about
the future
of the eu which is also
an important issue many people have
questions about it
and
let's have a look to another video
message from dave koch from austria
dear roberta my name is dave koch and
i'm from austria and i'm really curious
how you and the european parliament make
the eu stronger so that we're less
dependent on events that happen outside
of our borders like the gaza power
crisis
how can we make the eu stronger so i was
trying to release them the text is far
away um well
that's
something that you know you see behind
you one of the most amazing images that
was the moment when young people came
from all over europe and told us
political leaders how we should make the
eu better stronger internally when faced
with global challenges sometimes within
our borders sometimes also outside our
borders which is what we are facing now
i would answer uh mr mr koko just ask
the question that we should have acted
much quicker on the energy union that we
should be able to buy gas
or electricity and renewables from each
other rather than from frankly our
enemies i think now is the time for us
to do more also on the environmental
front but that picture also shows to me
a discussion that took place that we
need to discuss
and we can't say use the word future but
also we need to discuss the gaps
we have seen over the past two years
when we needed to act together on health
we did it even though it's not strictly
speaking a competence of the european
union when we needed to act together in
order to make sure that we grant as
quickly as possible macro financial
assistance to ukraine we did it when we
needed to be faster on adopting digital
legislation we did it faster than ever
before
so there is the political will today and
i would like to harness that political
will and that is why the parliament is
pushing for a convention in order to
fill those gaps are we not in time to
discuss is it not now the best time to
have an energy union is it not now the
best time to have a health union i think
that is what our citizens want from us
and that is what we need to deliver
and then the very last question again
about the future that comes from inigo
let's have a look to the screen
so an ego on facebook was saying that
every day more people are realizing all
the aspects of the eu but i also found
that the vast majority of people do not
know anything about the eu in your own
personal experience what is the best way
to proselytize the wonders and some
mistakes of the view
thank you and have a nice day he's
wishing to you so basically how can we
communicate better in the future about
the eu
i think we need to be honest
and i think we need to be open
we can sometimes we
we allow criticism to be leveled at the
european union when it is not the
european union's fault but sometimes we
don't say where we could have done
better
where we failed
and we don't say mostly where we have
succeeded so it's all boils down first
of all to openness transparency fairness
being
the home
not only if you live in a city in a big
metropolis but in any town and village
across the european union you need to
feel part of the european union and you
need to know that everything that is
happening
how you can pay your bills
how you are facing medical shortages how
you are going to make sure you have
equal access to health and education
that is thanks to the european union we
don't say that enough we don't say that
this is what the european union is doing
i come from a country where
people know who their members of the
european parliament are i would like
everybody to know who their members of
the european parliament are i would like
members from all countries and now
candidates as they gear up for the
election in 2024 to knock on doors we
don't only communicate virtually let's
after two years of being only online we
also need to meet in this kind of
setting we need to go to all doors to
all parts of europe and say we are here
talk to us what would have we done wrong
what would have we done good let's
improve it because the european union
can always improve but we have to be
ready also to take leadership in that
and this is why i have started since my
election to go to each and every member
state to talk to young people to listen
not only to stay in the in the main
cities but also go out into the
countryside and encourage ultimately
young people and everybody to make their
voice heard
the opportunities in 2024 let's take it
so that we continue in this constructive
pro-european project that we have
because europe at the moment there is a
czech presidency in charge is a task but
let's be up to it
well that's a very beautiful message
very inspiring message for the end of
our interview uh 20 minutes this time we
hope to see you another time
next time we have many questions that we
receive on social media on together.you
community so we hope to see you next
time and thank you everyone who was
watching us
and stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you